Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
And we are back with death metal and this is we're almost done.
This is the second to the last part.
I guess it's actually a seven issue series instead of six issues. Honestly,
I don't really even check online to see what the reading issues are for death
metal anymore.
I just kind of letting it go and just seeing how far we get into it,
but I'm pretty sure we have one more part left. Um, but here's the thing.
So in the last video that we did, the last part of the story,
we had this scenario where we basically saw the superheroes on earth,
pretty much eradicating earth, right? Just eliminating the entirety of,
of earth itself, right? The earth populace, all that kind of stuff.
And the reason why, and I think it was,
was something that was a little bit murky in the last video that we did.
So we're going to try to clarify here, the reason why is because in DC comics,
this is called prime earth, right? It's the main earth of DC comics,
the main universe and the entirety of the dark multi-verse is based off the main
universe. I mean, I guess to a degree, it does involve alien races out there,
but for the most part, DC,
hasn't really specified that instead the entirety of the dark multi-verse,
it seems to hinge on the entirety of everything going on in the main DC on
multi-verse the main DC prime earth,
because of the fact that whenever you look at the dark multiverse,
you don't really see like dark versions of like the red lanterns from like,
you know, the, some, some cast off planet somewhere is malt.
You don't really see like a dark version of the guardians of the universe from
like [inaudible], or I guess really old as it's called now.
You don't really see that instead.
It's all just dark versions of earth-based characters and dark versions of
earth.
So it stands to reason that at the heroes wanting to mitigate the power of that
man who lasts that it would basically essentially wipe out the Earth's
population because with billions and billions of people come billions and
billions and even countless trillions of possibilities. Now,
even then it does require us to sort of cook the books a little bit, right.
Because one of the things that we know whenever it comes to branch universe
theory and the idea of opposite,
multi versus things like that is that for every possibility,
there's an infinite number of other possibilities.
And it literally just branches out to infinity.
So as long as there's one superhero here,
there's an infinite number of possible versions of that superhero in the dark
multiparous, every conceivable fear that Superman could have,
and even the fierce, he doesn't even know he has, right.
The fears on a subconscious level exist out there on the dark multiverse, right?
So it's really kind of,
of Scott Snyder in DC taking the infinite possibilities of dark versions of
characters and kind of reeling it in and saying there's only so many dark
versions of characters that we know of. Right.
So it's kind of taking what is in effect, an infinite number of possibilities,
and just artificially convincing them down for the sake of telling a story.
Right? And so, because of that,
the only real life that's left here on earth are basically the superheroes that
you see here. Right. And that's essentially it,
there really isn't anything else. Now,
the other thing that we saw is that you saw all these different versions of a
dark worlds that had been created by the Batman who laughs showing up on earth,
right. At least, you know, coming towards earth.
And so one of the big guesses they make here is perhaps there is,
there are no other forms of life out there, right? Because they,
they basically cut off the power of the Batman who laughs from all the crisis
energy that existed out there and his ability to create a whole host of new
worlds. So long as prepared has that power, the Batman who laughs does not.
And so he has a huge amount of power in the form of document hadn't,
but the ability to create different universes out there doesn't necessarily
exist, right. His ability to do that has effectively been cut off.
And that's why they, the superheroes kind of guests and they say, okay,
with all the different, you know, dark versions of ourselves that we see here,
maybe this is it, right. This is all the Batman who laughs has that.
There is nothing else there. Once these guys are done, do we basically win?
Right? And that's why they kind of pull out all the stops and say, okay,
then let's get to,
if the likelihood existed that there were other versions of these dark heroes on
earth, right? So they fight this army here when they beat this army.
Another army shows up when they beat that army. Another army shows up.
If we saw that it was going to basically be a war of attrition,
then the superheroes would S uh, stage their power out accordingly. Right.
They would use just enough ability to destroy these heroes and then kind of make
sure they don't exhaust themselves. Right. Nobody wants to have the rope,
a dope technique done on them, right?
When Muhammad Ali beat George Foreman by letting George forelimb pound on him
and hire himself out, right. And then go into the,
going for the kill on George Foreman,
the superheroes don't want to have that happen to them,
where they go ham on all these different, you know,
this army here and then have nothing left for all the different, uh, other,
other villains that show up or other twisted versions of themselves to show up
from across the dark multiverse.
And the other part of that is we actually switch over to wonder woman and, uh,
and Lobo. Now, if you guys recall with wonder woman in Lobo,
they're traveling to basically the world forge, right?
The idea of trying to find some way to essentially tap into, uh,
all the anti-crisis energy that exists out there to kind of become the
antithesis of the Batman who laughs right at the Batman who laughs and Perpetua
are tying into the energy that's created from crisis worlds that they made right
to the events of crisis on infinite earths, infinite crisis vinyl prices.
And those, those, you know,
those worlds exist because of the actual events that took place. Right?
So the dark multi-verse counterpart is the version of crisis on infinite earth
where the auntie monitor one,
but that dark multi-verse counterpart only exists because the crisis on infinite
earths event happened. If, if that,
and who lasts and Perpetua are tapping into that, you know, dark crisis power.
And then what it means is wonder woman, couldn't turn,
tap into the anti crisis energy, right? The idea of the antique monitor,
not winning, right? That kind of a thing.
They can kind of tap into those energies. If that's the case,
then what you should be seeing here in this space that they're in worse pitch
black or all the hopes and fears and possibilities, right?
Because what they're traveling through is basically a tunnel, right?
So imagine that like you're driving through some tunnel to get to some location,
all the cars that would be around you represent all the fears and the hopes and
things like that.
Of all the various humans that exist on earth because of the fact that all the
humans are basically gone.
There's only a handful of superheroes left and that crisis energy has
effectively been cut off. There's nothing here. And the,
the only real last hair that exists out there,
the only real horrifying concept that exists is now basically the Batman who
laughs. Right. And that's kind of resented by the fact that all the, the,
the versions of, of the twisted versions of Batman,
Superman wonder woman that all existed,
that are currently on the battlefield seem to have basically resided here at
some point in time, right.
Where they've all been pulled out and they're sent to that location.
But because the Batman who laughs is the only real terror that's left,
then it's all the fears that come certain, the Batman who laughs the forums,
he could take different things like that.
Now they're not getting in a tangible form yet. Right.
Because right now they're just fears that exist.
It seems like it's not until these fears manifest in the physical world that
they suddenly take on a form. These twisted versions,
things like the Batman who laughs is actually the Superman who laughs or it's
the wonder woman who lasts or the specter who lasts or something like that.
It's just a concept once this, this concept leaves this, you know,
a theorial plane and it goes to a place like earth prime in DC in the,
in the DC comics. Uh, then it turns into the physical form,
the specter who lasts or something like that. Right. So it's just at the moment,
it's just thoughts that can actually attack them. But for the most part,
the other thing that goes on here is the actual confrontation between the Batman
who laughs and perpetual. Remember,
they're still fighting over dominance of the universe.
There's no Perpetua kind of plays this gambit where she's like, look,
you have to understand here. I'm the only thing that's holding back. Those,
you know, power's out there from realizing what we've done. Right.
And that's one of the things that Scott Snyder kind of hit on it.
And this is one of the things that also applies to Marvel comics, right.
That Perpetua is in effect a kind of stand in for like the one above all,
if not like above that in Marvel comics. Right?
So a Marvel you've got the one above all, and then you have like,
whatever's above it, right. If they're is anything model's never said there is.
But if there could possibly be a thing above it,
then those seem to be the individuals that recruit creative perpetuate as well.
Because what VCs told us here is that these individuals that created Perpetua
and basically sent her on the mission to create the multi-verse,
they're the ones who run the omniverse and the omniverse is basically a
collection of multiverses. And so the omniverse in, in cases, comics,
and in cases, you know, spawn comics and different things like that. And so,
you know,
if we extrapolate this out and we're really delving into the realm of hearsay
and just guesswork, what if we, if we extrapolate that out,
then we can largely make a reasonable assumption that these Omni Versal entities
that exist out there that could create a, create a Perpetua.
Seemingly also created a presence in DC comics that created the one above all in
Marvel comics, right?
Like they're the ones that are responsible for seemingly the existence of all
things that are out there now,
DC really seems to be playing it pretty fast and loose with that.
And basically kind of, and not even really fast and loose,
more kind of hard line and saying they're only well for the creation of DC,
right?
So seemingly these Omni versatile forces that are out there basically represent
like writers, the writers and artists that create DC comics. You know,
that really seems to be the actual explanation DC is giving us.
But if we move away from that actual explanation,
kind of replace it with our own explanation,
then they're basically the ones that created everything in existence,
across every form of media ever, right? Television, movies, comics,
actual novels, different things like that.
The one thing we do know is that perpetuate was not supposed to do any of this
stuff. You know, she was basically sent there for a task.
She deviated from her task and now she's basically gone arrive.
And so her being able to kind of block the actions of what she's done and the
multiverse as it exists from the eyes of these Omni Versal forces that,
that live out there, it's really kind of her saying, if you kill me,
they're going to become aware of what we've done and what I've done,
and they're going to wipe us all out and they're going to start all over again.
Right. They're effectively going to reboot as we it.
And so the Batman who laughs is kind of like, so who cares?
And so going on the attack again against Perpetua,
ultimately he ends up basically destroying her while he destroys Perpetua.
And actually in cases her back in the source wall and then siphons off the rest
of her power, right?
So he now has 100% of all this power across the multi-verse,
but the saving grace from all this really comes from wonder woman, right?
Where the book that she has in her possession is the one that would allow her to
basically kind of tap into all this anti-crisis energy and then use it for her
own purposes.
You were her in Lobo or basically cornered that ultimately Lobo kind of
sacrifices themselves and says like,
I will stay here with these copies of myself.
And I will basically fight off this,
this Batman who laughs as much as I can get outta here. Right?
Like I will be the distraction. Get out of here as fast as you can.
And basically save the day.
The problem with this is that she loses the journal and the process,
one of the Batman who laughs forces basically gets a hold of it and Lobo
essentially sacrifices himself. And so when she shows up to the forge of worlds,
then what this leads to you is basically this kind of formation of dark side,
who says like all is basically lost here. There's nothing you can do.
But in this moment, right now, what few hopes and fears exist out there,
really what few hopes exists out there? Come from your superhero,
friends on earth, but there's not really anybody left, right?
So there's no real hopes here by so the possibility of new alternate realities
being created based on the positive hopes of people who exist out there is
basically null and void. It doesn't really exist.
This forge is dwindling out and when it totally burns out,
it'll be because all your friends died. And then from there,
no new life will be created.
It'll allow the Batman who laughs to wipe all this away.
And the basically re you know, replace it with, uh, with his,
his depiction of how life should be kind of like a dark multi-verse 2.0,
basically. And so with that in mind,
wonder woman kind of starts pondering all this writing kind of starts thinking
about all this. Now,
the funny thing is once Batman who laughs overtake Perpetua,
he kind of starts to reel back his forces.
And when they all basically stop fighting,
that's when the superheroes make the false assumption that they want this to be
all the supervillains, all these dark twisted versions kind of stop.
And it's like, okay, we've won. Right. We drove them back. We demoralize them,
right. We,
we basically saved the day and that's when Batman kind of hits on the idea
something's wrong here, right? Like, something's wrong.
Like things are changing, right? Things are shifting. And that's when,
when even Jaro and almost anybody else who can subtly pick up on this starts to
realize the earth is shifting, right? Like the earth is shifting,
it's adjusting, it's modifying. We didn't beat anybody. We've lost. Right.
The Batman who lasts, took over perpetuate, she's gone.
Now he has absolute power across the multi-verse. He is in effect God.
Now there's nothing we can really do to stop him.
But wonder woman kind of starts to realize this thing where she starts to
realize, as she ponders this idea, she starts to realize what the,
what the journal had basically told her that this machine quote,
unquote kind of a loose term, you know,
this machine could be used to make everybody remember all of history, right.
To unite everybody in a single mindset of we're all part of this massive
tapestry. Now the question is, what does this mean? Right?
What are the consequences of wonder woman taking this revelation?
That they're all part of a massive tapestry and kind of focusing it into the
lasso and then dumbing it down into the world force.
What's the importance of that? Okay. So here's what this means, right?
Here's why this is so significant.
So let's wind the clock back to two action comics. We're one with nine in 1938.
That was the very first appearance of Superman and DC comics because of the,
the hilarity of Superman.
You saw a whole bunch of other superheroes being introduced, but in DC comics,
it wasn't until that man is Superman first crossover,
that they had a shared universe, but in the aftermath of that shared universe,
suddenly it was all these superheroes that exist out there all live on the same
earth and they all fight various criminals and they can all team up at any point
in time. Now in 1956, DC introduced Barry Allen.
They basically got rid of Wally West, the replacement with Barry,
but they never offered an explanation as to what happened to Jay Garrick.
And so DC fixed this in 1961, I think with a flash of two worlds storyline.
And what this did is it basically said any superheroes that you saw out there in
DC comics that were fighting between like 1938 and 1955 or so,
they were all basically from a place called earth to all the superheroes that
you see now with like Barry Allen going forward, that's all earth one.
They introduced the multi-verse for the very, very first time.
Now this became very chaotic and it became very hectic. And so in 19, 1985,
86, 87 DC basically rebooted with the original crisis on definitive event. Now,
in the aftermath of the crisis event,
you got rid of the multi-verse and you only had one universe, right?
That was the end of it. It was just simply a place called new earth.
And so in that universe, a lot of the heroes got new origin stories.
They got new, new tales, right? New adventures, different things like that.
And that ran all,
all the way up until we got to the new 52 at the flashpoint event,
which rebooted yet again, between those two stories,
we got events like zero hour crisis and time where the universe was kind of
blinked out and then blink back into existence. Again, we got infinite crisis,
which brought back the multi-verse and then you've got final crisis,
which made the heroes aware of the fact that the multi-verse had returned.
But after each one of these prices, events, new stories were written,
new origin stories were given. And so what really kind of happening here is,
is DC is basically telling us,
and really Scott Snyder's telling us after the events of the Christ independent,
our story,
nobody remembers anything from before the events of Christ's on defenders,
right? Nobody recalls that in the aftermath of infinite crisis.
Nobody really seems to remember the events from before infinite crisis and the
aftermath of the events of flashpoint.
Nobody really seems to remember anything from before the events of flash point.
And then when it comes to smaller stories, like zero hour and infinite crisis,
final crisis, that the heroes who were changed as a result of those stories,
don't really remember anything that came before it. Right?
So it's kind of this hodgepodge, you know,
sort of organized chaos among all these different heroes in terms of what parts
of their history they remember, what parts they don't want.
It's just kind of a patchwork,
just gaps in their brains of things that just have, or have not happened.
What's going on here is Scott. Snyder's basically clean, slating everything.
And he's saying, okay, okay.
So what if after the events of crisis on infinite earths heroes remembered life
before the events of the crisis, right?
They remembered like what life was like before then they remember their origin
stories, all that kind of stuff. And then they remember fighting during,
during the events of crisis on vendors. And they remember it,
the singular universe that came after. And what if, you know,
in the aftermath of the events of flashpoint,
they remembered everything that came before point.
You remember all their history and all that kind of stuff and stuff.
Instead of basically treating these stories like reboots,
where the characters were totally reworked, they treat them like events, right?
Like it's no different than like, you know, some,
some Batman versus Superman story where like they fought for a little while and
then they kind of go back to doing what they were doing. They recall doing that.
They recall all that stuff.
So it's basically DC saying none of the reboots ever happened. Right? I mean,
I guess they did, but like nobody forgot anything. They remember everything.
They remember everything that ever happened.
Superman remembers his life when his comics were being published back in the
1950s, right. Superman remembers dying.
Batman remembers having his back broken by bane and the original band, you know,
uh, wasn't nightfall storyline. You know, this, these are,
these are all now in continuity. And so there is no such thing in DC comics.
Now of that story is not in continuity.
The only exception to that are the L's world stories.
But like in terms of everything that's ever been published in DC comics,
it all happened now, but it all actually took place, right?
There's no more differentiating between the, the, you know, the,
the publishing of DC before crisis and after crisis that doesn't exist anymore.
It's all in continuity stuff. That's basically what this means.
That's why it's huge. It's a massive moment, right? It's,
it's one of the biggest things. And so with all that being said,
wonder woman is now completely powered by all this anti crisis energy and comes
emerging out with the intention of facing off against the Batman who laughs more
so than that because of the fact that all the heroes remember all their history.
Now they're unified in a way that they don't recall because all the,
all the previous adventures that they had together,
they forgot about they now remember, which makes them even closer.
They're more tight knit than they were before because they know the sacrifices
that the heroes that were lost that are still gone. Like all that stuff is, is,
is a huge, great big thing now. So this is awesome. It's colossal.
It's why I told you guys,
this is basically kind of like a reboot slash not reboot, right?
This is DC's version of secret Wars in 2015 with Marvel comics.
It's what it feels like. So with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
Probably the single biggest development I'd say in DC comics in the last 10 or
15 years, if not ever, but if you guys are new here to come and to explain,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you do.
And I will catch you all later.
[inaudible].